all right let's do this what do you got
for me buddy yo what's up quickly uh i
know i'm off topic but thanks anyways um
so i missed it and kind of brainstorms
took a couple of notes um
mainly because it was a fun problem this
is this is a solution to
the solution to the decline yeah okay
so um
the the problem stems from the bottom up
right it's the same with the denial and
the red pill
that basically it's very hard for
existing people
to to solve the problem so you would
want new um people that's the same thing
that you see with exhibit a where the
people voting they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're doing like very small
amount so what you can do is make the
kids um smarter right
and um what i was thinking is that if um
if we have
like someone who's alpha retro then
pretty wealthy so they could start a
school but also a very good start is
already what you guys are doing okay
okay stop stop stop because we got a
couple things there to unpack so you
you're saying make kids smarter
yeah that's the problem okay so one of
the problems that we have with that
though is that the public school system
which most children are in now probably
90 95 percent of kids in the school
system are in the public school system
which the government runs they set the
curriculum
they set all the mandates
and
almost all of the teachers are female
and they're of course liberalized and of
course you know selling all of this
woke rainbow politically correct stuff
um
i mean schools have three bathrooms now
here like i don't know where you live
but schools here have three bathrooms
there's male female and then there's
undecided i'm just calling it like
undecided because that's really what it
is it's like you know they can't really
figure out what what gender or pronoun
they want to use so they use that
bathroom right this [ __ ] did not exist
when i was in school this is like brand
new like manufactured stuff okay
and we're the only species on the planet
that does weird [ __ ] like this
no other species does this we're the
only one that have so much time in our
hands that we say you know what instead
of having a guy's bathroom in a girl's
bathroom let's do the undecided one in
case you think you're a fairy today
right so that's how they roll but
all of that influence comes to almost
all of the kids by way of the state so
how do you how do you fix that yeah
because i thought it's because parents
like used to have a nuclear family like
mom would stay home take care of the
kids dad would go and go to work and
then the government figured out well we
can double our
like our uh
tax revenue if we get women into the
workforce and then we started having
this narrative like you go girl you're
strong and independent you don't need no
man all that sort of [ __ ] and divorce
has skyrocketed and more women went into
the workforce and they started paying
lots of taxes so then kids because women
still want to have kids
need to be looked after by someone so
rather than homeschooling them you don't
have that option they have to go to the
public school system or in daycare so
how do you fix that like you know start
with that
yeah so what i was thinking there is
there are some prerequisite
prerequisites whereas um the families
that could do this are maybe wealthier
but there's also a solution to that so
i mean if you're talking the top five
percent maybe like two percent of the
world population in the beginning in the
beginning yes so if but if we get
someone who is
wealthy enough to to make it
cheap who well i'm not saying i know a
specific person and i'm i don't know
exactly okay so that raises another
problem so let me just explain that to
you okay most billionaire
entrepreneurs you know the guys that
you're describing
yeah
are betas right like they're like yeah
exactly okay yeah so
warren buffett is he an alpha is he a
beta
that's probably beta i guess right
elon musk is he a beta he says super
beta holy i was so [ __ ] because i like
the guy
yeah right you know like me too uh jeff
bezos you know the guy from yeah also
man jesus yeah basically dumped his wife
for some second-hand dirty sanchez right
like yeah like what are you thinking bro
yeah um well i can keep going down the
list right like all of these like you
know bill gates like dude's as beta
looking as he comes right like he's plug
like you know he's he's he's on the news
telling people to get vaccinated right
so all of these
billionaires that have all of this
wealth they're not red pill you know
unplugged you know successful alpha
males they're all plugged in betas very
successful plugged in betas okay very
very successful in fact and they also
drive
the decline narrative right so
which one of these guys is
going to pony up for you know let's just
call it the trp school of life
yeah um so well
if you would like to get like huge
changes that that could maybe be a
billionaire but i think as long as let's
say we get like 10 millionaires around
the world which is even beneficial maybe
even start online because i was thinking
okay probably the best way to learn is
in person but we have a thing called
youtube which is probably the future of
learning
where self-learners like me because i i
look at myself as self-learner if those
guys start acting and the first thing
that we need to do
is
like i always check the source of the
information like if you would be
uh poor and fat and whatever i'm
probably going to listen to you
but you're not that so if we can teach
kids like all right this teacher does
that like
then we can have good sources of
information and slowly start doing that
and if all the guys watching like we
have a thousand people their kids start
doing that and their kids start doing
that maybe like 50 150 years down the
line we can have a slow progress but it
didn't take us one day to get here and
then it won't take us one day to get
over it yeah i know but i mean like the
thing is is that is that you're relying
on a lot of up in the air variables
which i don't see
um
coming to fruition if i can be honest
with you yeah i can't see you know the
government a lot like
relinquishing control of the school
system and it like it's not educating
children today it's indoctrinating
children today
it is
yeah just be nice because i've got a kid
in the school system and it's like the
amount of work that i have to do
to
undo a lot of the lies and narratives
that that that get thrown
it's it's pretty considerable right like
when i was a kid i'd come home from
school and i would practice the times
tables you know with my parents because
that was part of the curriculum i'm
having conversations about why you would
assume somebody's gender with my kid
yeah yeah right it's completely yeah she
doesn't know how to do the times yet
right but like you know conversations
like that or you know the option for the
undecided bathroom you know exists like
these are the topics of of conversation
there's really like i love that
everybody's like okay i think that you
know we have possible you know solutions
here let's overtake this government
let's do this let's change that let's
but
all of these things you know rely on a
big paradigm shift which i don't see
happening man yeah yeah that's why i'm
just like hey you know what oh
i'm going to talk to you guys about
about this operation um that a guy in my
group came up with which i think ties
into aaron cleary's operation evil once
i get off with marcel what else do you
got for me on that do you got anything
else you think that's um potentially
what's the best thing that you got there
yeah well i think the the youtube part
because if and and and the the basic
concept of that it will take time and
i'm not trying to like really save the
west and everything i like i agree with
all the things that you say i'm kind of
like trying to make the best of a worse
situation and it's a fun
challenging thing so youtube
more and more people start listening and
then teach their children slowly surely
we can make the best out of this
situation that was uh basically my uh
solution yeah hopefully it made more
sense than the problem like you said
something earlier like why would i trust
you if i
didn't see you as you know successful
and you know put together but yeah a
good chunk of the population is is like
watching youtube content like brain dead
youtube content
um and in many cases
without a
verifiable source right like a lot of
these content creators are are just
doing voice over stuff you have no idea
what they look like right like they
could be a 400 pound neck bearded
tomato farmer living with their mother
yeah whatever you know what i'm saying
right like you know like we started to
see some of this stuff but they have a
lot of people's attention right yeah so
there's really a lot of battles out
there you know it was really the point
that i was driving at last week and also
what i'm driving at here is like you've
you know you've got a lot of battles out
there to fight and it's like okay we'll
pick a hill to fight on right because
there's a lot of them out there or it's
like i can just [ __ ] walk away from
all you hills over there and i'm gonna
go and set up my own hill over here
right and that's why i make the point of
well you know if
if you see the writing on the wall then
just enjoy
what it is that you can control which is
within you know the scope of your own
life right because i mean you'll go
mental
like everything that you ticked off okay
all of those might be you know good
ideas and potential solutions
but again it's a massive hill that that
you need to take away from the other
side
to get your way to work
yeah yeah basically eating an elephant
you don't do it in one bite
well yeah and the question is whether
you should eat the elephant as well like
right i'm probably more on the camp of
uh doing my thing you know mental point
of origin and making the most out of my
life and trying influencing
people but yeah
that's that is my solution for them okay
cool all right thanks bro yeah you're
welcome
you